the Jonas Brothers make it a double date
night Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott talk
about how they avoid the Kardashian
curse as Connie's ex Tyga faces his
fears on Celebrity Fear Factor everyone
this is the daily Denny and one of the
hottest new couples Priyanka Chopra and
Nick Jonas hit the town and how do you
beat that well you make it a Joe Broz
double date Nick and Priyanka went out
for a three-hour dinner in New York City
along with Joe and his fiance Sookie
Turner and if you look closely right
behind them yep
kevin is there - don't worry keV my
middle name is fifth wheel so it's cool
Priyanka turns 36 tomorrow and she told
us recently that she's going on a secret
getaway but Nick if you're listening bro
your girlfriend says she is not the
chocolate and flowers kind of girl I'm
super romantic
I'm super mushy and I think why not you
know when you love someone or you care
about somebody making them feel special
and giving them attention is the most
important thing well it looks like
things between these two are heating up
and the job Rose seemed to approve of
Nick's older woman this is actually the
second double date they've had after
their fourth of July bike ride so why
all the PDA well here's what Nick told
me about how he's handled relationships
in the past I have regrets about not
being open with relationships in the
past you know that's that's the thing
that makes it actually more challenging
is on many levels you end up trying to
hide the relationship or do things to
try to keep a private but it actually
just puts more stress on the
relationship so guys I gotta know where
do we rate Nick and Priyanka on the John
and Chrissy scale of relationshipgoals
I'm vibing the solid seven for them but
I actually can't tell if that's too
generous or not enough so you guys gotta
let me know meanwhile it's another
couple making waves today Kylie Jenner
and Travis Scott are taking a page out
of cardi being off sets recent magazine
cover story the new parents are gqueues
latest cover stars it's their first
joint photo shoot which is a little
surprising because up until now they've
kept their relationship so low-key
they've been together for about a year
and we know Kardashian romances get all
kinds of crazy but Kylie
Travis explained how they've avoided the
dreaded so-called Kardashian curse of
failed relationships quote we just go
the extra mile to keep our relationship
private and Travis tells the Mack Kylie
AXI likes me for me Plus let's be real
Kylie's man also stays out of the moguls
way she's only 20 but Kylie just became
the richest family member even more than
brother-in-law Kanye her cosmetics line
has made her worth over nine hundred
million dollars but it seems that
doesn't matter to Travis
named 5 Kylie cosmetic products store no
no like products like baby I don't know
about okay Travis had me hollering in
that clip by the way you know was that
long ago that Kylie had her arm around
another famous rapper Tyga he narrowly
avoided the kardashian-jenner madness
but now he's trapped in a much different
predicament as a contestant on Celebrity
Fear Factor in the premiere of MTV's
Celebrity Fear Factor rapper Tyga gets
trapped in a tank of ice quickly filling
up with freezing water my hands went
numb instant
I couldn't feel a thing and in my head I
just thought I'm about to clean right
now it's always funny to see people that
you've seen in other aspects of
television to compete on this show you
think you know someone because of their
personality on another television show
and then they get on here and they make
you realize you didn't know that person
that's all the fear factor revival
became MTV's highest-rated series
premiere when it debuted last year a
double win for host Ludacris who also
serves as a producer but don't count on
seeing the rapper competing on the show
himself any time soon I think I in you
and I into any of these challenges yet
man they won't allow me to participate
in any of these things I would have part
of the face in that keep you safe - yeah
my ability issues that's what we in this
nice trailer don't ruin that face Luda
are you guys celebrity Fear Factor
premieres tonight on MTV and I'll have
more of my interviews from the set for
you guys next week until then tomorrow
I'm bringing you a special San Diego
comic-con preview and then starting
Thursday we are taking the daily Danny
on the road and will be hosting the show
from the console prepare yourself guys
you've got a lot of comic-con goodness
headed your way
goodbye